well growing allegations of voter
suppression are emerging in the
hard-fought race for governor in Georgia
polls show the contest between
Republican Brian Kemp who is Secretary
of State and Democrat Stacey Abrams is
basically a dead heat civil rights
groups are suing Kemp for putting more
than 53,000 voter registration
applications on hold mostly from
minority voters and Monday dozens of
black senior citizens southeast of
Atlanta were ordered off a bus bound for
the polls for early voting Nancy Cordes
shows us how the fight over access to
voting has become a key issue Nancy good
morning good morning County officials in
Georgia say those senior citizens were
told to get off the bus because it was
parked outside a county facility and
thus constituted prohibited political
activity activists called it an
intimidation tactic in a razor tight
race that's been consumed by a fight
over voting rights the votes are being
purged in Hinesville Georgia it was the
talk of the race I want them to remember
that people died for that right they
were there to see Democrat Stacey Abrams
who is vying to become the first
african-american woman governor in the
south
she's running against Republican Brian
Kemp who currently oversees Georgia's
election system Abrams has accused him
of dropping more than a million voters
from the rolls since 2012 and closing
polling places in african-american
communities he is someone who's been
tilting the playing field in his
direction and in the direction of his
party the biggest controversy surrounds
the state's new exact match law that put
the registrations of 53,000 voters most
of them african-americans on hold
because of discrepancies in the way
their names are spelled in state
databases Marsha
Appling Nunez got tripped up by a
missing letter it was unnecessary that I
had to go through so many hoops to be
here right now finally as a registered
voter on Fox News
Kemp called the issue a smokescreen
those folks that are on the pending list
all they have to do is go to the polls
show their photo ID and they can vote he
says he's just enforcing the law and
that if you want to vote your name
should be recorded accurately the
challenge is that he knew from
experience that this law has a
disproportionate effect on certain
communities because he was sued for
exactly this reason in 2016
Appling Nunez told us she has now been
rear edge' stirred despite that missing
a but only after going online more than
40 times
Kemp's campaign declined our request for
an interview but in a statement said
that Abrams is trying to create fake
outrage to drive voters to the polls
Gail thank you very much Nancy but some
of the discrepancies though are simple
as a - is not there or your numbers
transpose I think everybody agrees no
matter what yes right more people should
vote there were more than 90 million
people that didn't vote in the election
election shouldn't be that hard to vote
and that's a case where every vote is
going to matter in that race